I'm here someone how do it do it from a
stroke quickly
that's the Sadler's with Peter Stan Stan
k-much oh I almost almost got it 90
percent tell me it's time to commute ah
there we go so we're gonna we're going
to talk about our mutual interests and
stoicism how what Peter's been doing
he's a member of the stoicism the modern
stoicism organization used to be called
stoicism today that's why I get a little
bit yes today's the blog actually oh
yeah yeah it was it started up being the
name of the thing the whole realm of
organization now it's just the blog and
so modern stoicism where any work as
colleagues together and Peter is an
author he's got the English edition come
out yet not yet but I'm working hard to
make that so he's an author essentially
in two languages Oh actually you are
because you published on on blog that's
to polish in English about about
stoicism he's his works in Polish are
some of the most popular on stoicism in
in Poland so they're serving yes so
we're going to talk about whatever we
want and various doing stuff it'll be
sort of a back and forth conversation
right yes all so who asks the first
place well here's one for you so what
got you interested in stoicism at the
beginning in the first place um there is
a I kind of it's like a two-fold story
bit because on the on some level I just
kind of got attracted to it naturally
just happened organically I got more and
more involved and then I realized that
certain things about stories that there
are certain people who work with choices
in the modern style perspective and then
I realized that back in Poland and then
I realized that what I would probably
something to add to what they have to
say and then I realize that I have so
many things to add that they need to
write the book and then I just sit down
sit down to write the book and I wrote
it and apparently it wasn't just useful
for me useful relevant for me only
because the partly was a kind of a hit
so I didn't it made me an expert in my
first answers that happened like very
organically yeah and of blended in the
topic and who on that and it was like
it's just ongoing research not going
like intellectual journey and
intellectual enterprise and the second
answer the more catchy answers that as
probably most or at least many of us
have got back in 2006 I got a bit of a
mighty king gear in my life nothing
happened like nothing big happened but
just as it happened a decade
yeah later but I was just trying to sort
things out and put things in order in my
life and kind of my life on a better
track toward goals and so on so on and I
was 23 years old I was quite young and
that finding I kind of needed a platform
to do that and because this kind of
organic growth of interest in station
was already happening it in my case this
platform appeared to be stoicism and I'm
pretty grateful for that so yeah so you
know you're talking about learning about
stoicism and writing the book and I
think a lot of people who haven't
written things sort of think that that
you know writers they have everything in
mind at the beginning and then you sort
of like trying to get it down on the
page but was there more of a process of
you know you write a bit and then you
have some insights and you know with
this book this orange because the copper
is very visible in Orange this orange
book a stoicism I pretty much had the
idea well structure in my mind before I
sat down to read
to riding it actually I'm pretty
organized person so it's not unusual for
me to have it this way but since the
book was finished and then published I'm
still growing and developing ideas new
interpretations of stoicism I use
Facebook color to propagate those you
know you use happen after the book so it
is so again it's a two-fold answer
I had a clearer idea what I want to put
in the book that's that's a fact but
also I my views has been having changing
a lot since it was published and I'm
still doing new things are some of those
also in the things that you've written
in stoicism today oh yes a perfectly yes
that's a lot yet though for example this
piece about stoicism and work yeah and
stoicism after Auschwitz these were the
things that I kind of either invent came
up with after writing the book or just
didn't manage to squeeze them in the
movie exactly this is how it happens I
believe that star system is never like
is closed and fixed set of dogmas is
just constantly it needs to develop it
needs to change evolve and to shape that
evolution and my my experience is
happening just that it's happening yes
yeah so how do you see the you know the
classic starts the ones that we still
have text from are they sort of touch
stones that we have to keep going back
to are they raw material for us to work
from either I know you don't think of
them as sort of infallible authorities
as if we have to you know apostolic
succession things like that but how do
you do them first of all we don't have
the basic facts that we don't have the
apostolic succession this is what
Lauren's back versus in the opening
parts of his news Tyson that the promise
that for almost 2,000 years these types
who disappear it was just non-existent
and our basic framework basic pattern we
need to work with is to try to imagine
what this time school would look like
today had it had this long 2,000
your long apostolic succession so this
is the one of the key points here first
now but basically I do think that the
ramen I mean the Starks of antiquity
gave us certain a certain exposition of
the stock ideas that are true because
they're did that those eight years are
true and they have universal timeless
meaning the problem is that they were
expressed in a certain social political
historical conditions a certain language
and certain context and what we need to
do is to kind of try to verify our try
try to translate all that into our own
language and into our own conceptual
framework and this is and exactly in the
in my book projects and the book seven
and I want to this is exactly than
trying this is exactly the framework and
I'm working with I do heavily rely on
the work so mark Salinas caters and
Seneca but the whole thing's is about
how to interpret them and make them and
bring them back to life so let me ask
you something sort of at the opposite
end of that I mean there's there's
there's quite a lot of popular stoic
literature out there and it runs the
gamut some of it has almost you know no
or just tangential connections with
these classic store walkers are those
actually stoic works or should we see
them as sort of stoicism light as not
not being you know being something like
a entry point but not fully what we're
looking for I think we should be open to
facts on the ground since you have to
deal with that whatever happens there I
mean I believe that there is it just as
you said there is a range there is a
gamma two approaches to stoicism and
positive probability in my in my night
you Lawrence Becker's book is one of the
most poor oh and most serious like
theoretical and economic yeah it's a
great work works and it's just as if
there is a from down from there there is
the slope of you know more popular and
more kind of semi stowing yeah
books and but just as I said before the
slices 'm has never been enclosed church
of you know six dogmas so we we need to
be open to the fact that there many
books and stars that are kind of not
really coherent with what these times
have to send we need we have to kind of
tolerate that right I mean there is no
yeah there is no Pope there is no there
is no Oracle who says what's stoic and
what's non strike so we just I think
some of the people that I've talked to
are that worried about you know the sort
of not all that stoic but sort of just a
life hack stuff Swamp Thing yes
absolutely indeed my view is is that you
know if it gets them looking at
epictetus or Marcus Aurelius then then
you know that opens up room for us to
work with them and once once you
actually spend time with the classic
works most likely you're not going to
you know stick with them most likely or
at least hopefully yes because there is
this risk there's this problem that in
2017 in the world of you know there is
kind of a risk that or a tendency that
stoicism as a commodity you might say as
a commodity or this set of like a life
hacks yeah or is it just another device
for you know making yourself a better
person so and so and there is this kind
of a you know there is this risk of
making it too superficial yeah and to
like shallow and and of course would
whatever is shallow and like flashy it
sells better and that's the problem
that's the risk and I think in the way
that our stoic do do is to kind of be
aware of that and trying try to you know
keep it afloat optical and not I mean
things will get
where do you want to go to a team to
wider audience and it will always happen
but we need to you know keep in mind who
you are and keep in mind that we need to
keep it philosophical still I'm not you
know let go away to too far from the
original message do you think it's
possible to grow a much larger audience
which seems to be what's been happening
over the last 10 years with yes
installers definitely that you know
there will be sort of there's always
gonna be a whole penumbra of those who
are only engaged with the most
superficial things yes
yeah nicely but are we building a bigger
and bigger core of people who you know
maybe aren't reading of course Becker or
Chris gills books or you know Julianne
says any these real great great thinkers
but but our yeah but our but our
engaging you know with the the class of
texts and I are practicing it I think
that they my impression is that the
interest in stylism is steadily growing
and then it will be growing in the
foreseeable future will start probably
will never be like you know Barack Obama
or the Beatles this level of popularity
yeah or CrossFit or but CrossFit is
actually attainable this candidate I
mean okay maybe not literally CrossFit
stoicism is the CrossFit of this year
but it will be growing right I mean
there is they were all there will always
be this type of people that will find
starting boring or unattractive or kind
of they just want get it but the
interest is universal it starts
indefinitely answers certain certain
need so that is that is universal
perennial and the demand for sizing will
always be there and it will be growing
so that's what that brings up another
question do you see stoicism when it
comes to these perennial needs of the
human soul that's exactly stoicism as
like the one path one path that's the
best one path among many possible paths
you know first so for example if
somebody says well you know I'd rather
use the Aristotelian tradition as modern
starix I think that star season has has
helped me a great deal has helped me
Bigley yeah in my own life and in my
personal dealings with myself and with
the world but I do believe that we have
to give latitude to people that they
they need to choose on their own what
they want we have to our duties to
propose a stoic way but what they choose
it's eventually up to them do you think
that other things that you there are
those ways you mentioned for human for
us as humans and one of the things that
interests me and that I'm working on is
to kind of kind of juxtapose certain
ways and try to verify whether they go
together who's Tyson or not that kind of
it oh yeah yeah where were the
compatibilities lie yes what are the
limits of stars' ISM when it can be
applied where they'll be apply that kind
of stuff is this is an important thing
and this is something that interests me
so that actually brings up another good
topic some you know other people who are
doing that like Donald Robinson I'm
thinking about where does stoicism in
its NCDC connect exactly this is one of
the examples yes so we're you know we're
part of a community of inquiry we read
each other's books a lot of course I
can't read your book and polish
unfortunately so I'm looking forward to
the English coming out so they'll have
but you know we you know we look at each
other's things and I think sometimes we
disagree with each other or respond to
them is that an important part of is
that important part of modern stoicism
is that an important thing in stoicism
is history I've been always a part of
social history yes the star system has
never been you know twelve system yeah
it has it has evolved he has the
multiplicity of voices in mind underst
mistress Tyson this is how it happened
always and this is what's happening now
definitely and absolutely if I reach
someone who I disagree if I this is also
the intellectual maybe this particularly
is the intellectual stimulation so yeah
I'm grateful for that
absolutely that's how it works and
that's that's how it should work I think
yeah I I'm in total agreement with that
I think important traditions developed
continually by my engaging interlocked
engaging and she'd storms yeah I think
about cruciferous cruciferous was a
everybody you know yeah we don't one
fortune we don't have what he wrote we
don't have the screenshots yeah yeah
well you know here's another sort of
just totally off-the-wall questions yeah
something knowing that so there's a lot
of misunderstandings of stoicism I often
you know all right you know I'm excited
to go to stoic on in Facebook or on
Twitter and then I've always got people
oh you can't be excited if yes right and
I said well actually there's there's
rational joy so that's what would you
say your what are the ones that you
encounter the most about excited noises
am a general story system in general
people tend to think that this is
something that called the the the
conservative misinterpretation okay of
stoicism is the idea that it's like
someone who only passively accept faith
but in the literal sense it is that
stoicism specifically so quietism
exactly exactly and lack of any
political or source or social engagement
this is something completely disagree
with I think that the stoic part is much
more active I than people usually thing
and and in any way that is actually an
active life yeah but of course and I
think the classics totally understood
yes this is kind of a very serious
misconception another of course is about
emotions that you know this twisted
stereotype that is that study some of
the kind of
suppressive Oh always absolutely yeah
this is something I disagree with
completely and also another one which I
call the ascetic misinterpretation of
space isn't that the historic is
actually a monk who only bread drinks on
the water
and does nothing enjoyable yeah avoids
pleasure in that which is something
again I did these are the Mist
misinterpretations I yes I need them all
the time yeah I mean the aesthetic thing
static ascetic thing yes almost as if I
think some people think that it becomes
valued for its own sake there's there's
no popular treatment of stoicism and
early modern philosophy where they saw
this talk is very prideful you know
withdraw from everything to show the
world that you know you have no control
over me yes I'm the umbrella think I
would put it this way that people tend
to think that the spoink is someone who
would drop yeah withdraws from the world
withdraws from using the wax pleasure
strike food doing not control other
things
withdraws from being an active part of
the world the social life
exactly social life in the center you
know detaches him or herself from
society or from in a bank engage in
positive on social stuff and this is
exactly what they disagree with
I think Stice ism as the after all
started with the materialist philosophy
we our Styles don't believe in
transcendence we don't believe in heaven
in afterlife and that kind of stuff we
believe in my opinion that the the world
of ours is here and now and this is the
world that we need to live in flourish
and thrive in this world not any other
place not in heaven not in like a desert
if we can let me go and we avoid society
we don't do that kind of stuff
that's mine yeah you know it's
interesting that you bring up the monks
I do you know a lot of work on monastic
literature yes exactly and monastic
literature and art which they don't go
together well they drew
if you look at like John Cassian and
people like that a lot of what they're
doing in working on the self is similar
to what what the Stoics are doing and
then when you read monastic literature
like accounts of monasteries you see
that they you know some of the monks
were doing this let's withdraw from
everything like Peter Damian and others
were just having a good time the way of
the spark is not the way of the month
yeah these these two pops you know what
I asked you a question that's sort of
along those lines you know when we look
at the monastic communities there are
people in the present who are trying to
do something similar to what the you
know what the monks would create what
they call them tensional communities yes
and this is sort of the broader term
describing everything from you know the
Quakers doing doing their thing to you
know traditional monasticism and
Christianity or Buddhism what would have
you to people who you know say okay
we're gonna be a CO housing project or
something like that do you think there's
you think that has any relevance for
stoicism you know it does it doesn't
help them to even out community yeah to
be involved with definitely modern stars
is something yeah the organization I
mean and they like stowing camp in your
course toy camp why only because there's
no you know in the international
community lasting a few days yeah but I
don't think it is necessary to be for a
modern style to engage in that kind of
activity I think that slicin can be
performed in many ways and yeah so it's
hard life like hi hey
very good oh we're we're learning things
yeah right now for the next maybe ten
minutes or so
Wow what do you think we could have 10
minutes yeah okay exactly
so what was the question oh we were
talking about intentional communities
especially I believe that they are
useful but not necessary or a modern
Stein we can be stikes whatever actually
wherever we leave and whether we are a
part of the larger community of sites or
not it is particularly in the time of
the internet and use that to be a part
of an intentional community
quote-unquote on the internet online
that this happens I have a decent
experiences that well we run it for that
if it had exactly the answer or not
you know we emailed back and forth let
said let's meet at this place that we
got you know yes tickets to online yes
yes absolutely so I mean if the next
question was to be about using social
media and computers and modern devices
in general to you to do star system my
answer is perfectly and greatly yes I
mean this is how it goes in the modern
life and we are starts with students and
we mustn't
I know blind ourselves to the new
developments we just deal with that yes
that to our purposes and this is
something I do this is something that
modern sizing does as the organization
and this is how this is how it goes yes
I have no problem so let me ask one last
question that do you think it's you know
stoicism seems to be of all the ancient
philosophies the one that is getting the
biggest traction having the greatest yes
definitely do you think that there's a
you know embrace of modern technology
plays a major role in that or is it just
that there's something going on a
stoicism and then the modern technology
is sort of amplifies that it amplifies
yes that's exactly how it works I think
we in general I would say that the human
soul isn't changed isn't trashed by the
advent of the internet maybe yeah is
challenging to her
correct but in general what technology
does it amplifies yes exactly and there
is this kind of a perennial award star
system and its perennial great timeless
value and once we once the internet
arrived it just kind of multiplying that
it was always there now it can be seen
more easily the website that you run the
blog oh and so and so and this cell
house and the important factor is that
it allows people from all over the world
to connect with you yes yeah and it's
really it's really pretty awesome to be
part of yes well thank you very thank
you very much yeah
you